we begin this morning with President
Trump accusing the FBI director he fired
of lying under oath at the White House
Friday mr. Trump said he is willing to
testify before the special counsel
overseeing the Russia investigations
that was the president's first comment
since former FBI director James Comey
'he's explosive testimony before the
Senate Intelligence Committee on
Thursday afterward mr. Trump left the
White House to spend the weekend in
Bedminster New Jersey
Erol Barnett is traveling with the
president Erol good morning good morning
president Trump is trying to spin
James commis congressional testimony
both ways mr. Trump implied the former
FBI director lied and that he exonerated
him as far as being the subject of any
FBI investigation and all of this is
increasing calls for the release of any
taped conversations between the two
which may not even exist no collusion no
obstruction
he's a leaker on Friday president Trump
said fide FBI director James Comey
statements were a type of vindication
frankly James Comey confirmed a lot of
what I said and some of the things that
he said just weren't true mr. Trump also
denied he told Comey to drop the FBI's
investigation of former national
security adviser Michael Flynn I didn't
say that so he lied about that well I
didn't say that
I mean I will tell you I didn't say that
in his testimony watched by nearly 20
million people Comey said repeatedly he
felt pressured by the president mr.
president United States with me alone
saying I hope this I took it as this is
what he wants me to do no I didn't I
didn't obey that but that's the way I
took Comey was also disturbed by the
nature of a private dinner with the
president who he feared might
misrepresent what was discussed he said
that's why he took contemporaneous notes
which were later leaked to the press
after his dismissal I was honestly
concerned that he might lie about the
nature of our meeting and so I thought
it really important to document the
president denied ever asking Comey to
pledge his loyalty I hardly know the man
I'm not going to say I want you to
pledge allegiance who would do that
who would
ask a man to pledge allegiance under
oath I mean think of it I hardly know
the men it doesn't make sense
the president also teased an
announcement on the existence of taped
conversations in the White House and you
seem to be hinting that there are
recordings of those converse I'm not
hinting anything I'll tell you about it
over a very short period of time okay
okay do you have a question here when
will you tell us about the room for a
fairly short period of time oh you're
gonna be very disappointed when you hear
the answer don't worry it was three days
after President Trump fired Comey
that Trump said the former FBI director
should hope no tapes exist but combing
does Lordy I hope their tapes now to get
to the bottom of all this the House
Intelligence Committee has sent a letter
to the White House requesting any tapes
or quote recordings or memoranda of
conversations between the president and
the former FBI director Alex a similar
letter was sent to the former FBI
director James Comey Errol Barnett and
Branch Berg New Jersey thanks Errol